foreign
let's go to Atlanta home of the most
absurd
airport on planet Earth and talk to
Janelle what's up Janelle
hey Dr John what's up how we doing
I myself to breathe I'm so nervous
why why are you nervous I'm not great at
this you know
no you're awesome because I'm talking to
you and I'm like okay so it's like
millions of people probably listening
and I'm like oh my God I'm so nervous
Janelle I make up all those numbers
there's like 38 listeners
no you don't Max uh thank you thank you
so much for taking my call I really
appreciate it
all the time you've helped me with so
many things that have been going through
my head and
um I just want to say thank you and I'm
it's such an honor to get to talk to you
it's an honor to talk to you I'm really
grateful
um by the way while I've got you
please do whatever you can run for
public office do whatever you can fix
fix the airport what are we doing oh I'm
working on it I barely fly out of here
it's so ridiculous so by the time you
walk from the front gate to your like
gate you could have driven like all the
way to Nebraska anyway that's a whole
different conversation what is up a
whole different conversation all right
so like hit me with it what's up
okay so um I'm gonna give you the back
story and then I'll ask my question
it'll all tie it in so bear with me
um so my husband and I we've been
married for 12 years
we have two kids
um we got married pretty quickly it was
a pretty brief courtship so a lot of
things you would find out about your
partner before you get married we kind
of found out after we were already
married so it was kind of love awesome
first couple of years you said that you
said that so eloquently
some of the things you find out
beforehand
um we found out after afterwards but the
way but I know what that probably means
and the way you said that so gently so
you're Delight okay keep going it's been
12 years I I trust me I get it right now
so our main problem or my main issue has
been with um infidelity with him mostly
just internet issues and texting and
messaging and Facebook and Instagram and
so forth
um we've been to counseling quite a few
times three four times on and off
um he's also done individual counseling
a couple times and then things seem to
be pretty good for a while a few years
and then you know things happen and we
kind of end up back here
so um a few months ago he started acting
a little bit differently going out more
staying out a little bit longer very
protective with his phone and accusing
me of cheating so um the light bulb kind
of went off and I was like okay
something's going on here so
um about a couple weeks ago I decided to
do some investigation
um so I went on his computer and I saw
that he was on a dating site
[Music]
yeah so I I catfished him
um no way
I sure yeah way
you did did he fall for it oh he sure
did uh this is my favorite call ever
ever yeah hey can we call him right now
and I'm gonna pretend to be uh
the the husband of the person please
please
oh my gosh
um all right the thing was I knew it was
probably gonna happen because I know my
husband
so um I created a fake profile I was
messaging him he was all for it oh
you're the worst and incredible all at
the same time
dinner and lunch and um he's saying he
was on divorced he did say how two kids
though so at least you know that was
something so
um so then I started I was going along
with it and I was going to you know meet
up with him yeah
make a date with him and record it and
we'll put it on the show but but this is
what happened I kept looking and I came
across too
um credit card receipts and I saw
um like two hotel receipts ah yeah it's
not funny anymore not funny anymore yeah
not funny
[Music]
in our city he got it for a friend
don't buy it and the other one that was
not in our city it was when he went out
of town to visit family and he said he
didn't want to stay at their house so we
got a hotel I didn't buy that either
because people just told me about it he
didn't he had me thinking he was staying
at his family's house and he wasn't so I
didn't buy any of that
um
so my husband has a tendency so the
counseling has been going through over
the years we've kind of figured out and
he landed it that he has an issue with
attention and validation and it's like
when I'm not hold on hold on Janelle
Janelle Janelle Janelle
your husband cheats on you
period period yeah I have problems with
validation I don't get meet women in
hotel rooms across the country
yeah I know I like to
um
for my wife should tell me nice things I
like for my wife to tell me she's proud
of me I like to fill in the blank
yeah you're right so so you can go to
counseling and learn all these neat
things and all that kind of stuff all
that is a complete and utter wash
means nothing
if your husband is meeting other women
in hotel rooms across the United States
and then lying to you about it
then you just period end of discussion
and here's what I think is is
unfortunate is that you
are so kind
and you are so there's something inside
of you that has told you that you don't
have equal value to him
that you have come up with some really
complicated narrative as to why this is
mostly your fault
foreign
that is not a true story that you tell
yourself
you're married to a Serial cheater
period yeah
yeah he's a guy who steps out on his
wife repeatedly and I've said on the
show I'll say it again I have a ton of
sympathy for
um
a business trip one night stand I have a
ton of sympathy for I met somebody am I
saying it's right I'm saying if somebody
sits down and goes dude this thing
happened
things happen or I was working on a
project with somebody for a year at work
and I I just fell head over heels I get
that this is
persistent and ongoing he's spitting in
his wife's face telling her she's stupid
you're so dumb you can't even find out
and when you're looking at receipts
he's like you're an idiot and you for
some reason Janelle believe yeah you're
probably right
even as you described you know listening
to you even as you described
the story about him going to see family
but staying in a hotel when I promise
you when he was there he was telling you
that I'm at Mama's house and she's
whatever
you the way you told that story if you
go back and listen you don't fully
you're not 100 that you're right
you're about 85 I'm telling you you're
100 right
yeah I know
and you probably don't want to be a
statistic you probably
have done whatever you could do for the
last decade to keep his family together
and you're married to someone who's
doing everything he can to unwind it
true or false yeah
yeah you're right
all right and I've got like a like a
knot in my stomach talking to you right
now
like I'm sick right now
did you tell them that you uh
or catfishing him did you tell him or
does he even know that yet yeah yeah he
knows
in front of him it all came out
um
he knew then he apologized and you know
acting remorseful than saying
he wasn't gonna go and yada yada which
is a lie of course he was going to be up
of course that's a lie
foreign
so the real question is less about him
the question is about you
is my marriage fixable
I think any marriage is fixable quite
honestly
right but I you can't fix it alone
period
and quite honestly you've tried for for
10 years
you have to have a man that will tell
you the truth you have to have a man
that will tell you I'm sorry and you
have to have a man that will not end up
in a hotel room with a bunch of other
women he's not married to
are you perfect in this marriage no I
don't I don't even know and I'm telling
you no of course you're not no right and
has he weaponized any imperfection to
give him Liberty and license to do
whatever
he wants to yeah absolutely
and you're worth more than that so are
those two little kids
let me say it this way I I'm gonna I'm
gonna take back my answer
ask me your question again
is my marriage fixable I will answer it
this way no
your marriage as it was is over
can you and your husband build something
completely new yes
have you heard my twin towers analogy
oh yeah okay same thing what y'all had
is over those Towers have fallen down
they are in rubble and in Ash and smoke
and there's dust everywhere
choice you have to make and I think
right now it's it's the initial choice
is you alone
are you gonna walk away from the towers
and let nature take them back
or are you gonna sit down with him and
say from this point forward we build
something new and here's my stipulations
here's what I need to move forward
and then you'll go get some
professionals to help you rebuild
something completely new
and that might mean new jobs that might
mean moving that might mean everything
is different because everything is
different
right I mean you see what I'm saying
oh
my guess is you've had some dark moments
like where you're just sitting in the
shower when you're finally by yourself
and You Weep so hard you can't you can't
catch a breath Fair
yeah that's fair that is so true I'm
just wondering why you know why me why
why this what what is it that I did no
you can't you can't your husband made
some bad choices over and over and over
and over and over again
and at this point if I'm being super
Frank
um
I'm worried about your health and safety
I'm worried about him bringing something
home from some woman that you don't know
about or multiple women that you don't
know about
it and I like I'm I'm as concerned for
your safety right this second as I am
for your marriage
I am too
I said we have to definitely go get
we'll get tested because I don't feel
I don't feel safe
Janelle sweetheart where does this come
from
who taught you that what you feel in
your guts is so wrong
because you've known he was cheating on
you for a long time
I knew and even the way you just said
just now like yeah I told him about
there's an uncertainty
instead of a proclamation at your front
door
you don't come in this home until you go
get tested period and you showed put the
you hand me the results
like who told you that that you're worth
so little that the what you feel and
what you think and what you need is of
of secondary importance
okay
it didn't help that I see myself in my
parents relationship
where they're still together but I mean
my my dad practically cheering on my mom
the entire
45 years has been
married
so it's what your body knows right
yeah yeah
except the rules have changed in the
game has changed and Janelle my friend
Janelle's not gonna take this crap
anymore
here's why
because your two kids aren't going to
repeat this thing
right
they're gonna have a very clear picture
in their head of what either a strong
boundary and self-worth looks like
and a single mom who cannot be stopped
come hell or high water or
they're gonna have a ringside seat to a
couple fight and scratch and Claw their
way to something so remarkable and
strong and beautiful moving forward
but they're not going to learn
this is what marriage looks like
yeah you're right Fair
you're absolutely right now this is the
part of the story where like in the
movie When the Music swells and then
like the Montage scene happens this
isn't but that's not reality reality is
this do you work
not right now
um I got laid off a couple months ago
and I'm looking for for work now okay
this kind of self-proclamation has very
real economic consequences
right it sounds easy for me sitting in
Nashville Tennessee with a with a good
job to say you should just and that's
why I'm not gonna do that I'm not gonna
tell you to run out today
because there's a real question of where
do you go and how do you feed your kids
how do you eat right
right that's a very real thing and you
know as well as I do the court processes
are so jacked up it takes so freaking
long to get anything done
right
and so I would here's my my I mean I
just love talking to you you're a fun
you're funny you're
you're like
you're such a great personality
thank you Dr John and I'm heartbroken in
my guts for you
and I I don't think I've told you
anything you didn't already know I'm
heartbroken in my guts because I sat
with women as they've walked what the
next two years of your life is going to
be and it's not going to be pleasant
and staying in this is not going to be
pleasant
you're right and so the path you have to
choose is not one of ease and least
resistance and one of really hard you
have two incredibly difficult paths
ahead of you
and so I always want someone to choose
the difficult path that's going to lead
to Freedom not lead to
repeating a cycle of abuse and you're
just going to take it and this is just
the way things are over and over again
and dude I I I'd love to talk to your
husband if he wants to call me
he won't he won't but I'd love to
he probably won't he won't no I know he
won't he won't
here's here's I think your next steps
are number one I'd go get a counselor
today
in fact I'll hook you up with three
months of free better help if you don't
have a counselor in your area um stay on
the line here and we'll get you a code
and you can call somebody and be on the
phone or talking to them via Zoom within
the next 24 hours
thank you and here's what we're talking
about you need to get somebody and I
want you to be very specific when you
ask I need a game plan
to begin to identify my next steps I've
been married to somebody for a decade
who cheats on me and cheats on me and
cheats on me and now he's spending money
out of our family account now he's
increased up an uptick in lying he's now
traveling distances and I need to figure
out what my next steps are and what
they'll do is they'll help you think
through boundaries think through do you
have a mom or dad's house you can go
stay up for six months with the kids do
you have an attorney do you like some of
those hard questions you're gonna have
to face
also here's a testing site I mean
they're going to walk you through all
those those questions the second thing
is is I want you to get a couple of
girlfriends do you have two or three
women in your life that you trust a lot
I do
I want you to take them out to coffee
sometime this week and I want you to
tell them the truth because you have
never told them have you
no it's time
you need some real people in your corner
in your local community that knows the
truth about what you're experiencing and
dealing with
and this is part of the the rising this
is when Janelle
begins to come out of the water like on
our own two feet and this is my life
what am I doing this anymore
tell me why that scares you to death
because because
I'm going to have to come out of my
yes it's everything's okay shell
yeah yep you have created the most
beautiful it's all great and I'm
hilarious facade yeah you're so good
you're so good
yeah
that is
an idea but you probably do because
we're a couple that everyone looks at oh
my God you guys are so perfect and it's
all great and
all that
yeah and so you're going to lose your
identity
the identity is the perfect married
woman
and we're going to change that identity
for the woman who tells the truth
and the woman who is stronger than iron
you're right over the years I've just
gotten less so the more it's happened
it's just some braver and braver I'm
getting as far as I need to leave I need
to leave
yeah but it's very very very hard to
leave by yourself
it is that's why I want you to talk to
these three women
and there's something surreal about
saying it out loud
even you started this call with me like
well and this is going on and he's got
some needs so bad that I I mean I feel
bad I interrupted you
I would love for you to sit down with
these three women over coffee or tea or
whatever y'all you like to drink and sit
down and go my husband's been cheating
on me for a decade
and now he's moved on to multiple women
in multiple cities and it ends now
and their jaws will hit the floor
and you can smile and say I didn't mean
to drop it on you like that but I for
sure meant to drop it on you like that
I need your help
and there's something empowering about
it because you don't want to say it out
loud because you don't want it to be
true and I love you enough to tell you
it is true
it's the first time I've actually said
it I know I can hear it on you I know I
know
do you trust me that there is I know I
know there's nothing easy that comes
next nothing
but you have a great picture of your mom
that hollowed-out shell
yeah that distant look
that Dad who walks in and out of that
house like he owns Planet Earth
yes
to you that's the trajectory
and that's if your husband chooses not
just a bail
or doesn't get somebody pregnant
all right
I'd call those women ASAP
like I'd call him today or shoot him a
text message and say we need to meet
tomorrow morning for breakfast we need
to talk
okay
oh my gosh I'm sick to my guts I hate
this for you I hate this for you I hate
this for you
I thought we were gonna have some fun in
a catfishing thing and this got real
real real fast
here's the deal Janelle um hang on the
line we're gonna hook you up with that
counseling and I'll be here every step
of the way
and um
you've got Jenna's contact info I want
you to reach out anytime you want to be
back on the show you want to talk
um I got you okay
what a mess
somebody threw a grenade in the middle
of your home and it was not you
but what comes next is going to be
largely what you decide
not by your hand but in your lap and
here we are and here we go
you didn't cause it
but you're part of the cleanup crew and
you're part of the what's next crew and
I'll be here with you